fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby go you know what's weird
you're gonna make fun of me you know
what's weird yeah is uh I know you're
gonna make fun of me and so are people
online the arowana fish it's from China
it's the arowana the arowana yeah it's
it's it's like worshiped by the Chinese
it's from the Yellow River the Yanks
yeah so it looks like a dragon and
they're very expensive so in the Chinese
culture that's why the red arowana is
illegal in the United States to keep
them like high valued in China yeah so
you can illegally you know get them here
yeah
I have arowanas I have three of them
somebody slides no hold on hold on but
they're regarded as super good luck
really really good luck they bring Good
Fortune since I got these three arowanas
yeah I've had nothing but good luck I
gotta get some
since I got these three arowanas yeah
nothing but good things have happened
well what do they say when the clouds
are overhead by marijuana that's that's
that's part X like that that stats guy
says and then but the the sun doesn't
seem like it's there but it'll it's
there you just have to wait till the
clouds part yeah and I so I remember
when I was buying the guy told me about
all this I'm like okay whatever and then
I get them and they grow an inch two
inch a month dude so they get huge your
luck keeps growing it's nuts man
[__] maybe I'll buy one not for me
though that's a big that's not a
beginner no no Advanced aquarium I gotta
tell you like I got I got attached I
really did get a little bit attached to
my turtle
and to my three [__] koi and when
that [__] raccoon yeah or that
well I don't know if it was a raccoon or
if it was a um by the way when I think
when I swear on YouTube we get flagged
only in the first minute no we we tested
it it just depends so it depends I
apologize for my language but that
raccoon or that cat
whoever it was when they when they
chewed my my turtle's head off
and I think her name is Isabella I can't
remember what we named her it must have
been really important is it Dora is it
Dora is the door my kids named her
Isador I think but you know uh chewed
it's hands and feet off you that's life
son of a [__] that's life and left him
on his back her on her back like so
undignified and then just one fish after
another just dupe and I was like where
are they and then finally it's just an
empty Babbling Brook yeah and I want to
put more in there but I know it's just a
desk you gotta figure that out you could
put but I was really I got I loved my
fish I would feed them every day oh
these arowanas are my pride and joy and
I feed them feeder fish like uh live
gotta watch out for white ick yeah you
do not know the tanks now are running so
smoothly the only way to like you could
introduce white egg is if I brought a
new fish in or if some of the feeder
fish I bought that do carry disease had
it but hey we have to celebrate your
birthday was last I was on Saturday I
know should we uh you know how to
celebrate my birthday I bet you you
bought a fish oh I bought another
arowana a jardini Arowana from Australia
very rare I thought they were only in
China well there's a there's one Scott
actually called a jumping wait so people
can get a piece of paper and a pen you
guys ready go talk about fish yeah it's
actually uh monkey uh it's called a
jumping monkey fish but these are uh
from uh Australia oh yeah yeah you have
to have a lid they'll fly out so so how
about the that's what I got is it perch
his name's bullet is it perch that so
I'm gonna be is it perched to jump out
of the water and hit people in the face
when they're when they're on a boat no
that's like Asian carp carp carp yeah
they jump out of the water and people
like oh that's amazing yeah cool and the
fish are like right in the face is that
right yes
I don't think that Asians they do that I
don't think why are they yelling out
there you go
Indiana
yeah that's what happened I thought look
at this it gets crazy bro you cannot
drive faster yeah but they're jumping no
matter what oh right in the water you
just had to drive through why are they
jumping through the water I think
because of this disturbance with the
motorboat it's like freaking out this is
amazing eat them no they're yeah so what
do you call that [__] oh they're ugly
I'm gonna be in Portland they're
invasive I'm going to be in Portland in
uh April at Helium yeah
um and uh but uh I know my my site
no it didn't get taken down I gotta just
I gotta pay I you forgot to pay the
website yes are you from 1994 from 1994
I don't pay attention sorry Brian count
that comes down but you can catch a
10-foot sturgeon
sturgeon are 10 feet long and I'm not
doing it though because I don't care but
you can catch one they're a 10-foot
sturgeon
look at the size of that thing that's in
Portland look at that that's Photoshop
no no I know this guy this guy's uh
they're 10 people yeah
that's a shark it's a monster those were
that's a dinosaur in France you'll
appreciate this Brian those arowanas
they trace as far as back they're around
when dinosaurs were out
that's all cool there that's why they're
good oh I will appreciate that yeah you
want one no I'm excited for you and I
wish
dinosaurs were around dude isn't that
crazy amazing dude their waters are
around the same time amazing and yeah
he's in my tank no there are fish that
are some of those fish are prehistoric
nice in my tank no I know longest lived
fish do you know what it is uh yes it's
a basic whale
it's a whale basic no but I like how
you're thinking I'm pretty sure
it's a whale so it is a whale but it's
like I think it's the Arctic shark
no it starts with a basic whale
Icelandic shark it's something like that
yeah I could type in what no no what's
the oldest living uh mammal
mammal yeah
140 million years wow that's in my tank
he saw he witnessed a Stegosaurus he saw
the uh now he sees me in my undies
Cretaceous Period that's awesome nuts
you know what I don't care about then I
should dinosaurs I don't care about
dinosaurs and I don't care about
astrology and I probably should like
like dinosaurs are cool no I know it's
just not a the bow head Whale okay they
can be um 211 years old uh wait wait
what I'm just living vertebrates
that's we see we were both kind of in it
that's I know you had it the bowhead
whale that's a long-lived animal
that's a warm 211 years
hey you know how long that arowana is
gonna be with me
how long 50 years is that true yeah they
live that long if you take care of them
right water conditions 50 years 50 years
you will almost get attached to it I'm
attached to it now close to 50.
so it sounds like oh no no no no in the
wild it's 50. okay 15's a long time
though because they get eaten or
something look sell it on eBay for 5.8
million bucks dude
that is so crazy it's Asian like you
know
in China in China they're called dragon
fish because they look like dragons they
have these long things like tusks that
stick out they're so dope dude
and they're and they're they're not
they're good luck
they're the most aggressive freshwater
fish you can buy they're the barracudas
of fresh water they're they're like
barracudas
do I put you can put worms in there
frogs which I would never I love frogs
are too cute but worms crickets
probably a little Sparrow or something
oh spare I put 30 in a time and they
last two minutes 30. you mean you mean
uh goldfish goldfish yeah
well you know I used to own um pythons
and you had to feed them rats you can't
do this can't do it I always felt bad
for the mice I didn't like it the only
reason I feel good when I feed these uh
feeder fish is
it's time to pay the piper you gotta
it's the Daddy's up and he's he's
bringing me good luck and yeah we're
gonna sacrifice you guys please keep
this in mind if if I had a a fish that
was brought me Good Luck which okay
three of them and and it only ate human
fingers okay I would take your hand and
I would shove it into that tank and I'd
be like you're gonna lose some figures
you got to keep this going that's the
bad news so you're not gonna play piano
good news is no PM yep I'll leave you
with your I'll leave you with this
finger and your thumb I can drink there
you go so you can drink I'm not gonna
take all your fingers drink and pinch
titties I'll leave you with two I'll
leave you with this which one I can
leave you with your it'll make me like
lobster boy from American Horror Story
I'll leave you with yeah I'll leave you
with I want to leave you with this I'll
take the two middle fingers do this so I
can do headshot Boom Big Leon Edwards
fan headshot well do you watch the
fights you need your trigger no I did
not watch the fight I did not that's
leave me like that
um yeah I could do that but uh good news
is I get good luck
I think how much more luck you give get
some arowanas
hey Brian listen you know I want to look
like a penguin yes listen
yeah you gotta we gotta talk about a
three-letter word that ends with X okay
and you're gonna probably experience a
couple of these moments when you when
you need this three-letter word that
ends with an X okay no I'm talking about
a tux oh my God I need a tux now you
need a good place to get a tux dude
because if we get if the if we're in the
Oscars next year we're up for awards
when he talks the black tux makes it
super easy to get on Trend top quality
guaranteed to fit tux cetos toxes yeah
but it's ever really tough you don't
have to leave your house take the tux
the black tux fit quiz pick the style
you want to rock boom boom boom your
toxic delivered to your door 10 days
before the day you need it this is
plenty of time to try it on make sure it
wears you well what happens if it
doesn't fit right okay well the black
tux fit guarantee oh my God I should
order a better size within a day or two
of receiving the less than great fitting
all right what if I don't want to go
online is there a story right away with
no extra cost if you if you prefer the
instructions yeah
has showrooms across the country they're
expert fit Specialists will help you
find the perfect style talks or suit
make sure it fits just right okay
that's the bottom line it's very easy
I've actually done it actually done I've
done it too they sent me when they're
great and you know my thing every day
your arms you know how I'm built like a
frog from the waist down yeah Daddy
needs that he needs you need some room
in the front that's right for your
wiener right or by the black tuxt it is
the best place to go when you need a
tuxedo for a wedding or a special night
right now when you go to the
blacktux.com spider and use code fighter
you will save 10 that is the black tux
t-h-e-b-l-a-c-k-t-u-x.com slash spider
code fighter to save 10 the black
tux.com Spider coat fighter
you get in an accident my friend oh dude
it can ruin you nuts bro and then you
got to try to hire a lawyer go do or
what about like my Grandma fell at this
famous restaurant broke her hip this
real story broke her hip she's like what
am I gonna do I went hey how about you
get a rack of ribs on us I went that
ain't right we're not going to stand for
it look medical bills what can I do
medical bills can bankrupt people oh my
god dude you got anything you have any
idea over five million crashes in 2020
alone think about that that's 600 an
hour all right it's a shocking amount
here's the good news yeah when you sue
somebody you're not suing the person
you're suing their insurance company and
that's how you get yourself made of
whole but don't I need a ton of money to
hire a lawyer usually yes but here's the
bottom line with Morgan Morgan it's free
if you're injured you go check out
Morgan Morgan it's the largest injury
Law Firm they have over 100 offices
Nationwide more than 800 lawyers they've
collected over 15 billion dollars for
their clients
proven track record and how's this when
you submit an injury claim with Morgan
Morgan it's so easy it's like using an
app okay it's basically six clicks from
your couch this is nice listen if you're
ever injured in accident you can check
out Morgan Morgan their fee is free
unless they win for more information go
to forthepeople.com fighter or dial
pound law
pound529 from your cell phone that's
Four f o r the people.com fighter or
pound law pound 529 from your cell this
is a paid advertisement
can you break down the fight for me the
Leon Edward Kamara Usman oh I sure can
be surprised it's on my birthday no I
called Leon Edwards I called it I also
had my friends put a ton of money on
Leon it's no [__] again I don't know
Leon I'm more biased towards Kamara I
know so why did you think Leon would not
would be able to keep Kamar uh Kamara
off his back
um because they spent prior to this they
spent eight rounds together and so Leon
has so much tape to watch improve on
it's gonna be the same Camaro you're not
getting a different Camaro it's gonna be
the same Camaro who's also older he has
knee issues there's rumors he only has
one or two fights left like it's Leon's
time and I just thought if his takedown
defense got better striking so much
better than Camaros it is huh and he has
a confidence from that KO which I don't
think he had confidence going into that
second fight he got that confidence it's
in your backyard there's just too many
obstacles for tomorrow to get over it in
order to beat Leon and then watching the
fight
um you know it's my birthday kids will
run around so but I was able to watch
for the most part
I was like man that was a close fight
I'm probably a draw because I would I I
gave when I was watching it looks like
it looks like Stickman strikes Camaro
out did him uh am I wrong about that no
no you're sorry yeah sorry sorry so
um watching it live again kids run
around there's Pizza there's cake it's
my birthday my weeder's out so watching
it
um first round Leon I was like holy [__]
he looks fantastic he looked phenomenal
yeah second round I was like all right
Camaro watching it live and not paying
fully attention but first round so I was
like all right it's 1-1 going to the
third third round Leon gets uh deducted
a point for kicking in or for it was a
hole in the cage fence grab yeah so I
was like oh this is bad news for Leon
and I was like I'll probably give uh
Usman that round so that's a 10-8 round
for Usman so then it's 3-1 uzman I'm
like oh Leon better get on his bike and
start getting to work fourth round Leon
fifth round Leon so I'm like that's a
draw
but then I watched it a second time
without my kids without my wife around
without focusing on my [__] good luck
fish right yep and I put my wiener back
in my pants and re-watch it Leon kind of
dominated it wasn't as close as I
thought in my head and you'd probably
give Leon I mean there's no no way you
would give him anything less than three
rounds straight up right definitely four
probably four he probably won four any
controversial things I heard the gay
Chief fight was very close but they gave
it to gaichi that's fair see I even
scoring that one I was I could see how
you get to visit the first and second
definitely number one for physive he's
just so fast and strong do you second
round I was like all right third round
definitely engage you I thought it was
two one physiv wasn't mad at it it
depends how you score it but would you
score would you score kicks you have to
hire no you have to score the same you
have scored the same but the judging
isn't there yet the judging isn't aware
of kicks they're not aware of submission
attempts takedown defense they're not
privy to all this so
um yeah and Justin did go for a takedown
landed take down the third round but
Justin looked good you know Justin
looked good physiva's an animal and
Justin did work you know Justin came out
in the post fight and was like uh you
know business should have been
commenting on this he's so biased I'm
like that doesn't work for me because if
Leon didn't win
then I could understand your bias but he
was excited because that you got to
celebrate the guy winning the fight you
got to talk about what the guy's doing
well who's winning the fight when you
re-watch the fight which games you
should do you'll realize that Leon that
put he won by a much bigger Gap than we
actually think yeah he kind of dominated
that fight significant strikes though it
looks like uh uh fees have physio
beat him got him well in the first round
and the second and the second that's why
I gave him the first and second Justin
definitely won the third yeah because he
had a big take down that one but I was
like it can go either way yeah nope
nobody got robbed it could go either way
it was a great that fight should have
been my only uh issue with that fight
should be in five rounds that should be
a five round fight being three rounds
drove me nuts they just started getting
rolling um but Justin's must see TV so
it's physique they're both of them to my
two favorite Fighters watch out would
you say 55 is the most stacked division
whoa 55 45 70 85 I would say 55 right I
mean I don't know 55 is tough because
they're older 70 stacks 70s [__]
stack there's a Changing of the Guard at
55. so you know that you know our boy
mockachev called out Leon Edwards yeah
get out of my face focus more on 55 yeah
you just beat 145 pounder right okay
cool I thought you lost the fight you
just beat the 145 pounder defend your
title at 55 instead of jumping around
who's there besides benildarius that's
what I want to see uh you have Darius
um would have been the big one and then
you have those guys coming up you have
some guys coming up the C55 is not as
deep as we think there's some big names
there but they're they're older like
they've been there a while so he beat
Charles Olivera he beat Dustin Poirier
of just engages in the area of Darius
you have Chandler you have physique who
just lost you have gamrat uh it's a lot
of names but it doesn't necessarily mean
look at 70. 70 you have Kamara who's
older you have Colby's there Hamza he's
never fine at 70 again he's going to 85.
Muhammad no joke Muhammad should fight
for title yep you have Gilbert Burns uh
Chef cat's a [__] nightmare
wonderboy's older in the tooth you have
Neil Sean Brady you know there's yeah
they're all about the same when you look
at it like this yeah that's true 85 70
55 I think 45 is the deepest 45 is the
toughest to win in anything
um uh your your thoughts on
bow nickel and
whether or not he takes the title in a
year or two years
two years I would bet my uh arowana's on
it you would yes a year no just yeah
just a nightmare wrestler though the
minute he grabs you he's gonna join you
no he is wrestling in submission yet but
I but I I think obviously he's got time
he's got time to develop a strike yeah
there's no there's no rush you don't
want to do that in a year no two years
yeah I bet my arowana's on it really
yeah now now I watched the uh the
wrestling NCAA Championship I I don't
miss it I watch all of it my boy at
least they're bowling he goes every year
too there's a kid from UNC he's a
five-star recruit I'm gonna tell you
something off air that I can't say on
this that will blow your mind about this
kid he's a five-star recruit out of
Greeley Colorado his name's not Spencer
way off way off let me get through it
right so Spencer Jesus Christ so um so
um he's a five-star recruit out of
Greeley Colorado had offers from Iowa
Oklahoma State uh Ohio State out of high
school out of everywhere everywhere he
goes nah my friends and family are in
Greeley I have a good Supporting Cast
here I bet I could still become national
champion from Northern Colorado can you
Brian can you name the last forget
Maddie Champion can you name the last
All-American no think about it think
about it I bet you can get this can you
name the last All-American from
University of Northern Colorado
the last All-American think about it
2010.
was the last All-American he fights in
the UFC
from Colorado Northern Colorado I used
to train with them he fights in the UFC
we're currently just fought
oh is it uh is it um Joe flat right you
just fought flat for Steve yeah
there you go okay there we go so that
was the last All-American I didn't know
just in case he was All-American yeah
yeah big time too big time yeah and then
was like yeah I'm gonna try MMA
and not wrestle athlete and not wrestle
from day one it's like apparently it
doesn't really trim yeah apparently it
doesn't train Jujitsu much
difference it stands in bangs that's why
you love them yeah
love them disagree on his Biz being
commentary but you got to love Justin
Gates
listen Kamara who's been him are best
friends and training Partners so he
thought uh Bisping was biased because
he's British British he's off on that
he's off Biz Wings Compton that's why I
love Bisping because it's from a
Fighters I love perspective and he had
such a good take on in the second round
when uh come out kept getting him the
nuts and like doing all this stuff come
on kept talking the rep be like he's
doing this he's gonna like love it and
this means like hey ignore all that dude
focus on the task at hand focus on
winning the [__] fight don't this
outside noise all these distractions you
gotta vote and he caught himself and
goes because DC goes you gotta dress
getting kicked in the nuts because he
goes no you're right
and I'm like you're on a business stick
to your truth bro you're [__] on it
yeah cause I've been hitting the nuts
and I'm just even it hurts like who
gives a flying [__] keep going dude keep
[__] going yeah it doesn't even spot
on dude spot up
yeah Michael if you're listening he came
to my stand-up I brought you backstage
we had a good time before the show
and then
he left and I wanted to say bye and then
like two years later I found he sent me
a beautiful DM oh you were so funny and
I never got I never saw it no you're 50.
I saw two yeah I saw it two three years
later Michael from Northern Colorado
let's give him his flowers dude just
think of this think think of think of
Finn what weights he play that uh uh
Russell right not fight I mean I think
it's 1 35 but think of this think of
Finn was a five-star recruit yeah Ohio
State Stanford Oklahoma State Oklahoma
Iowa is that him uh uh yeah Andrew
Alaris
I think all these five-star recruits
come to you and Finn goes no dad I think
you must stay here and wrestling Greely
you go no son you got to get out of here
yeah bring him up let me see some pics
oh bro bro and the guy he beat the guy
he beat was a former two-time Natty
champion
good Lord the guy he beat was uh he used
to wrestle it's I think Stanford and
transferred to Iowa Savage
hey beat him back give me a sec
really yeah wrestles at 135. but so
there's there's Big Ups that's like
Princeton had an upset in the basketball
tournament right yeah the biggest upset
was in NCAA Wrestling
and did you see the mom so this kid's a
three-time national champ he's going for
his fourth as a senior he gets pinned
dude pinned by I think a four or fifth
seed he hits pin bring that up chin he
hits [__] pin the mom do they show
the mom she's a sweet little lady
glasses he gets pinned she takes glasses
runs off
versus his opponent
no it's not this kid so dude biggest
upset in uh NCAA Wrestling 2023. dang
damn it's so it's so dope so he's gonna
you would have him come into MMA
uh when he's that good it was that good
and that young Olympia go yeah go get a
gold medal for America dude yeah
Purdue's dude oh there's I mean Iowa
Spencer right there yeah yeah yeah
that guy's exactly five foot three
what's this number four pin Spencer Lee
listen to the crowd biggest crowd ever
since Tulsa your lord and savior Donald
Trump showed up too oh my God how great
is wrestling
oh no no that's a pin you guys got to
realize this kid hasn't lost oh my God
how nuts is that how's that like
crazy you're gonna find a kid who he
hasn't lost Brian three-time national
champion
pinned him he had no business he he
should not have won that pinned him dude
and Lee won last year on two torn ACLs
yeah dude monster and Ramos pins him
nuts right it was great I don't know why
people don't pay more attention to these
who is that that's why I posted like
this is my my March Madness Tournament
that's the only one I care about so
who's Ramos he's not he's not the same
he's the number four guy in the world I
don't know what did he the next did he
two-time Hodge trophy so you know I
always say Beau Nichols won the Heisman
yeah this guy won it twice oh nickels no
no bo nickel didn't win the bow nickel
one no well the Hodge trophy is the
Heisman right
the Heisman well because the best the
best football players or the Heisman the
best wrestler in the Nations award the
Hodge so the Hodge is their version of
the Heisman right so I say Bo won the
Heisman you know it's just
twice I won it twice
twice three-time national champion
you just see these guys man then the
[__] work ethics [__] nuts crazy
well I told you I I told you that I went
to
Dan Gable's wrestling camp we train with
the Hawkeyes and the idea was you're in
high school obviously I was just 18
years old and you train they train you
the way the Hawkeyes do so what you're
training is you're doing three a days
three you wake up and you sprint you do
all those all that stuff live Russell
live Russell I'm telling you it's a
similar format but you're still not
going against Iowa Hawkeye Cowboys you
know what I'm saying like 100 that I was
17. and I got a sense I remember they
said we're going to train you this is
how this is what D1 this is what how you
train Like A Champion and I I I I I
limped I remember I limping for two
weeks I it was the only time I thought I
couldn't make it like really they they
pushed you that hard and
I I think that that's the main reason
that I you know people laugh but I'm
being serious like I went to American
program and I was like if this is D1
wrestling I don't want to do it and I
think I gave myself a psychostomatic
back injury because I would smell the
mats and my back would snooze up I feel
you I mean I I you know looking back on
it I think I was just like well I just
why would I now imagine American like
this other thing I think about like if
Michael Jackson is a low level D1 it's
not Oklahoma it's not Iowa that's your
job full-time job 50. but you got to add
this in mind too and I I I'm just you
know this but so when you are when
you're wrestling on that level okay and
you're wrestling pretty much year round
you're also sucking weight yeah so so
with Dan Gable like what would happen
with a lot of those Iowa guys this
happens with a high level wrestlers some
guys just go nuts so there's a famous
wrestler maybe it was I don't want to
say Lindley Kistler or something like
that it was a big big time guy and he
was an unbelievable wrestler I don't
think it was him but it was it was
somebody like that
and he was uh I think it was the day
before the ncaas he just couldn't take
it anymore he ran away they found him in
a [__] doubt like he was in a diner I
get it eating donuts and drinking water
he just couldn't take it I get it he's I
can't do it well now think about think
about your college experience as a
regular college student now take that
you're majoring in wrestling you still
get your major interest you still got to
get the academics yeah like the kid that
won at uh uh what's the uh Cornell you
won a World Champion uh naughty Champion
Cornell Stanford Princeton you still
have to meet the academic requirements
now imagine those kids who go there and
they focus on that now imagine
year-round run you're cutting away
imagine the discipline if you can do
this is why if you can be a wrestler on
that level and you're doing that you
didn't do anything you can learn
everything it's easy this this is why if
somebody has wrestling on their resume
every Fortune 500 company should hire
them nobody has more self-discipline in
the world than division one college
wrestlers not even close to it that is
and also to that to that degree the some
of the most successful people I know in
business are from wrestling background
look at Daniel Cormier who then went on
to be a a two-time Olympian so there are
no breaks that's just you know that's
why Bo nickel that's why these guys been
competing on such a high level for so
long so when they step into that octagon
it's very interesting because they're so
used to that they're so used to that
pressure when Metcalf won Metcalf at
Iowa won the ncaa's I think four years
ago maybe five years ago he won the
ncaa's and I I don't I don't think
people really understand how hard that
is how impossible that oh you got
emotional this guy was talking because
his dad was an Olympian and his dad
they're I forget where what country but
he's not from here Dad was an Olympian
in that country wrestling yeah brought
him over and he's like so how soon did
you start him wrestling his wings too
yeah he goes did you think that he was
become a national champion in America
and they're both crying well that's the
thing when you when you see that kind of
like so I was at Ben ask yourself it's
the work it's the amount of work I'm at
Ben aston's house and there's a guy at
the kitchen thing doing some cooking and
I I take him in as I do with men and
he's got a crazy thick neck and traps
well that's his brother his brother was
a 185 pound National Champion NCAA so we
got two of these in the family okay I
got it I got it yeah that that I think I
really do believe that I think if you
can do that you can do anything if you
can suffer what a name there he is Max
aspirin yeah there he is that's [__]
said at Mizzou
yeah he's a monster
there he is there he is
better looking than Ben in here yeah
he's he's taller taller and and I'm just
saying it is what it is yeah my
brother's better looking at me yep big
kid
hold on hold on
for a second
hey let that sink in don't say dumb [__]
okay
[__] huh oh you're humble is that where
you are you humble yeah
brand of shops humble yeah
yeah guys listen finally he's gone
let's talk is this alcohol
no no I wish it was
um
funny if I just ran out of [__] to say I
think this green really brings out the
pink Hues in my skin
that's what I'm talking about Nyack
everybody thanks for coming out Nyack um
yeah that's uh I love being
wow gangster dude yeah
doesn't it stink then yep
yeah we just noticed Brandon have socks
on get stinky so if they're brand new
I've never worn these and also it feels
good no socks right yes and also I can't
wear narrow shoes anymore so these are
baby powder though if you're gonna go
backless baby powder baby powder I do
that with my like loafers yeah leather
ones because I can't fit a sock in them
because my feet are too fat yep you
gotta have I like my toes to be splayed
everybody hey going back to I think I
get emotional when I see like that
National Championship kid how excited
they are that's why I think I cried
during American Idol because those kids
finally make it the only time have you
ever felt any the only comparable thing
I have which is nothing compared to
national champion or American Idol going
to Hollywood I guess
um but when I when I was on The Ultimate
Fighter after I knocked out Marcus Jones
I mean like if someone's like the
happiest you've ever been besides my
kids being born have to say that right
but um is when that tournament right you
know that tournament and I knocked out
Marcus Jones and I was doing fake snow
No Angels on the mat because it was like
oh my god dude you did it you did it you
did it there's nothing that's why when I
see those those kids on American Idol or
I see uh you know how happy those kids
are uh that was that was where it was
that was it right there there's nothing
like that and he broke it's so scary
possible and I was down in the fight too
and you had that knee thing I love that
story with Lauren Lando goes does it
matter what your knee what's going on
with your needs yeah because I went on
the ultimate fighter and before I went
in the house I had a really had a torn
uh ACL MCL like small frat like tear but
my knee kept swelling I went to Lauren
Lando shout out to Lauren Landau and I
go hey man will you look at my knee does
all the things I could tell it's not
great like what do you think it was does
it matter
does it matter so you know with Muhammad
Ali when they when he fought Sonny
Liston and Angelo Dundee they put they
put um the mafia had money on it they
put
uh a solution on his gloves that made
his eyes blind he couldn't see if you
watch that fight in that one um round he
he's doing this he can't see he had to
clinch he was doing this he goes I can't
see I can't see Angelo Dundee said it
doesn't matter let's go your eyes will
clear up it literally was that gives the
bisping's thing where you know people
give him [__] for it where he's like
none of that stuff matters it's not
gonna win or lose you the fight you
focus on the none of that stuff matters
in life actually it's like there are a
lot of excuses to not achieve something
and what I tell everyone good ones yeah
if you're down the dumps buy an Arowana
fish
bye spend if you're down guys if you're
broke and you're down in the dumps
Chinese borrow five thousand dollars and
buy legally illegally import a red
illegally import a red arowana it's
gonna cost you how much
I want one the size of my forearm
oh Bubba for for red or gold yeah from
China yeah uh I'd say seven day Grand
how much 78 Grand yeah and then I got
don't I have to have a k a cage oh
minimum 300 gallons don't say cake okay
see I don't know not a cage I'm not
selling to you well I want you to put
them in a cage I want good luck bro now
you know some people they want to get so
big you know how you have that pond sure
they'll put them in those ponds here's
the caveat though they need 78 to 80
degree
warm 78 to 80 degree very warm water but
people will buy pool heaters and put
them in those ponds so you can have
marijuana's in there something to think
about also use a stupid raccoon yeah
with an Arowana will eat that raccoon
stupid wet nose off is that true yes not
hearing it from a raccoon a big one no
no how big are they how much money you
got you keep you're getting the week
look up what feeds on on on arowanas
Jaguars Jaguars
three feet doesn't sound right that's
right it's large they are expensive uh
what do I ever want to feed on
oh no what what feeds on what are their
natural Predators oh what eats everyone
is
in the wild
top five arowana attacks
large fish
not much I don't stand that is
wow there you have it no predators
hey top five everyone attacks that them
attacking the people are just let's go
ahead and say it well I'll upload some
[__] that'll blow you did so we can't
play this obviously
oh it's a that's a mouse oh my God that
Mouse is doing the backstroke though oh
damn the mouse like what in the [__]
damn
I feel bad for that little snake oh my
god oh is that a snake no that's
attached to his face no that's his name
Mr wine that's a snake it's a little
snakey
yeah you guys won't be able to see this
we're watching a red arowana feed on a
straight up snake
oh he's a sick one and a freaking that
one ain't cheap there look how
aggressive he is just waiting for the
food boom damn they're fast
oh that's just data there was a little
there's a fish the fish lived this long
one thousand one one
get out this water's cold the squad is
called okay frog are people gonna be
mattified post The Feeding Frenzy of my
arowana and the the feeder fish oh
that's a cricket grasshopper here's
probably grasshoppers it dirties the
water man it's a real mess yeah they
stink
no they don't care about the smelly see
that's more natural at huge in the wild
well he ripped his leg off and now he's
eating the whole thing God damn
mother aren't they cool looking yeah
good luck baby
yeah they're no joke
no joke so fun dude they're so fun could
you get a baby alligator
yeah sure you can how much oh centipede
whoa oh those things scare me oh and
they sting too ow yeah that thing's no
joke
oh geez oh geez I I hate those things so
we're watching a giant black tipped
arowana it's a giant centipede eat a
centipede a giant it's kind of [__]
them up well centipedes Are No Joke no
is that guarantee bit the crap out of
him oh it's on his face that's why I
went I went ah it's dead he drowned it
it's like one of those big time
centipedes too that is horrifying yeah I
don't like centipedes they scare the
crap out of me
they're pizza oh God how disgusting he's
eating the whole sentence I don't say
disgusting though right why it's kind of
cool I don't think so I I'm I got the
creepy heebie-jeebies from Centennial
it's a dinosaur dude yeah I got they
they give me the heebie-jeebies I want
you to start telling your friends out
here Brandon has three dinosaurs hey I
had a dream rat Australia rat
that's not a New York rat that's a live
rat too that's cool Ah that's one of
those Malibu rounds
that's mean
poor little thing the one thing you can
kill is a rat nobody cares
I feel bad we all feel bad oh look at
that giant shark rat's like if I could
just get up on this heater yeah poor
little guy he's like he's freaking about
his tail though oh
okay I don't think he got him hey you're
mean
yeah all right fake plants sorry guys
we're watching bad things and I feel bad
I mean it's life though you know this is
life is this is in the
oh that sucks I think he's gonna drown
but that rap see but again why would you
give him the rat because the rat's gonna
bite his face I don't
yeah this sucks it's a little Majestic
okay now we're watching the torturing of
Iraq I know the Raptors got really sad
well the the the arowana doesn't know
what it is so he doesn't really want
that rat is swimming his ass off get the
rat out of there man the rat the rats
are good the rats
the rat doesn't I told you the time my
buddies in college had a pet python like
Hey we're gonna go on a vacation can you
feed him like yeah no doubt like he eats
mice I'm like all right I go to the
store they're all out of mice because we
have this big rattle yeah that'd
probably be better I'll take the rat I
put the rat in there
dude what the [__] you do to our goddamn
Python and what do you mean what
happened they go this is a rat in here
that ate the Python's face off
[Music]
that's why you can't put it I knew so
because I put that rat in here yeah you
can't put a big rat in there you can't
do it you cannot no the New York rat no
okay
are you kidding me come on I'm walking
here I have to tell you my my uh pit
bulls my girl's Pitbull badass dog just
a straight up for this back in the day
with a lot of people a lot of people had
pitbulls so this dog came from Florida
at a like corvino lines like fighting
dog just looked like a it was made it
was felt like a coffee table with supper
on it would grab rats
I take her to Central Park or I take her
to the park and I was in Chelsea and uh
right near the Flatiron building and
there's a there's a park there she
grabbed a rat at night I didn't I didn't
know what she was doing I would let her
run around she grabs that rat and shook
that thing so badly she shook it so
violently that a piece of rat got hit me
right I knew you were [__] I was like
yeah that never happened but hey it did
happen hey by rap do you mean homeless
a lot of problems wow has its own smell
to it too yeah not good bum diary is
different than regular diarrhea diarrhea
is really bad and and she would roll on
it I said it yep
yeah and then I would make her get no
stalker oh what do you want to do for my
birthday man I want to have dinner
and I think we'll buy a very expensive
bottle of wine
save the wine money buy me uh [__] off
okay no I'm not doing that I don't care
where you dumb fish okay I'm done
talking say that bad luck
I just pulled it back I just pulled it
back I want that I just pulled it back I
like arowanas yes you only like Airlines
I like air once you have three three can
I come over and pet one or maybe pretend
it's mine put your finger in there what
do I have to do to get uh I'll let you
see him okay
um dinner huh what do you think remember
I feel like you're like 40 years old
Brennan it's really important to Mark
these moments in life we don't do enough
of it no we never stop never we should
take chin we should take George we
should take like our people redeem and
do a holiday over there for us huh we
didn't even do a holiday dinner it's not
cool it's not good should we do a big uh
tfat caterer I would do it tomorrow
yeah I would we could call uh Marco at
uh we could call Marco and and I can
guess the table okay
where's my boys free you know he owns
scope but chin don't sound like he wants
to go oh yeah I'm done okay chin didn't
seem like you want to go for a second
yeah
so it'd be one two three four yeah it's
your birthday
it's my birthday can I bring my arowana
no invite Chris yes you say Chris Delia
yeah he ain't coming out he's like me
it's your birthday
for what
I mean this isn't working for what no I
know we'll figure it out though but yeah
we can translate up tomorrow
you want to eat a good meal
we do this
we do this that's how we catch up dude
that's true we just air it
yeah we've been talking the same we'd be
talking this way if we didn't have these
mics
happen to get paid for it well what wine
do you have you want to get some yeah
we're good
what do you got chance what happened
here you know you know when you get I
don't no I don't have children yeah
that's where you want to spend your time
oh it's like my my father-in-law we were
watching the fights you know I just like
to focus on the fight especially during
that main event I'm sitting there my
father-in-law who I absolutely love
Stephen goes hey you had a few drinks so
hey do you ever like um
like when the guys used to fight with
and train with you guys ever just get
together and go to dinner and stuff and
I'm like this is our third round when
all that concert is going I was like
what he's like do you ever do like with
the fighters he gets used to training
with you guys ever just get together
like absolutely not because you don't
because me and my boys that I you know I
was a cop for 30 years we eat together
once a month like a good friend
absolutely smart oh absolutely most of
my friends I work with I see that we
checked that box I go I also have kids
man well the clubs would always do that
right you'd see you'd see people at the
club all the time yeah there's no
Community like that anymore now like if
in order for me to see my friends have
to book them on the shows otherwise I'll
be honest with you I'd rather spend time
with my 11 year old and you know my 14
year old like my kids I don't see him
enough as it is yeah yeah let's see more
yeah my friend got mad at me because I
he said you're ghosting me I just
haven't called him because how old is he
he's all he's old enough to know better
is he old enough not to use the term
ghosting right I know and I and I said I
I was like he said you're ghosting me
bro
and of course I'm not I just I just I'm
so busy it's not ghosting it's just like
man I got the kids yeah I got kids I'm
I don't have time what do you got chin
all right now I got a text from
everybody from my birthday except for
you you know what's funny no here's the
thing I made him you guys I know I made
me a nice video and I I don't see it but
I heard you posted about me no so I
remember
once again I hated that picture your
lady sent that too oh nice I was in
cahoots with her I was actually making a
video for Brendan but then I'm like then
I'm like wait you guys always make fun
of us for saying Merry Christmas I used
to always say merry Christmas happy New
Year different chin no Christmas would
be like Christmas Thanksgiving Easter
don't need it birthdays big 40. you
trained me this way that's why I was
like you guys make fun of me I told my
girl said he's a son of a [__] I'm
trying to have a dinner and he's like I
mean we could
so I just stopped I used to always do
that with my birthday a little different
than Christmas but I can see it but
that's why I said my girl she goes did
anybody not text you hurt your feelings
I said I only want like you guys were
busy I get it that doesn't bother me
kind of did
um and I said the only one that bothered
me that didn't text me was clop he's one
of my oldest friend and then I was like
but I also it doesn't bother me anymore
because he has kids I I miss my
birthdays all the time and my girl goes
you're the worst that's why I don't get
math people forget mine but then um she
goes you've also conditioned your
friends because you joke around all the
time like don't text me don't text me
now they're not exactly well you're a
lady I was like your lady and I were
trying to plan something because if you
were gonna go to Austin I know she was
going to have your room
she was gonna have your room all decked
out happy 40th
and she's like I wanna I can't wait to
do something for me give me his uh like
when you find out what the hotel is
where it is I want to have like balloons
I want to have banners and I and I'm
like I'm like I'm on it but in my mind I
was like he would hate this he's gonna
come in and go oh man oh man thanks boo
yeah thanks uh this is amazing
she got married because she got me yeah
she's the best she got me those you
don't care about 40. say happy birthday
she's like yeah you're ballooning my
kids love the balloon she's like don't
you like your blue yeah cool balloon
she sent me a picture picture you made
she bought me that sweatshirt you posted
oh damn it it's an off-white sweatshirt
damn it Adriana is the mayor yeah the
man
there he is look at that right oh that
to me at a nice meal happy Portage to my
brother Brennan's job 12 years ago I met
this man and we've seen each other twice
a week ever since tough as Nails
creative but most importantly generous
if you do so much for so many
anonymously he's also into fashion
apparently he thinks this Peruvian
Poncho suits him so that's a dope ass
off white pocket look at us look at us
how about this dumbass good looking guy
hey look at this dumbass still
pretending to be friends
yeah whatever dude
now dude how about that that picture
we're wearing suits that was at the
guy's Choice Award it sure was you know
what's never coming back
well hopefully it does come back
eventually everyone can just take a you
know it's just having fun just messing
around it's all good you can't celebrate
guys hopefully eventually
uh Brian did you follow any of that uh
uh Jeff Molina stuff
I wanted to make a joke but you know I
love Jeff Molina yeah I feel bad for him
I don't know so I was gonna post uh
Brianna's new favorite fighter so Jeff
oh yes yes someone outed him he got it
was a video of him sucking weiner
yeah well [__] that guy who I [__] up
with that and that when I said on the
shop show I said here's my thing with
this
how trans you know bisexual gay just be
a human for a second imagine being Jeff
Molina and waking up that morning and
you've had this secret that you didn't
choose you have the secret that you have
to dealt with your entire life coming up
in Wrestling coming up in the MMA
Community you've had this burden of a
secret that you've been like man I don't
know when to do it you know I don't know
how I'm gonna do it but you just have
this burden you're carrying and then
some [__] for whatever who knows why
this terrible person did this releases a
video of you
sucking dick and you gotta wake up that
morning and go oh my God and that's how
the world finds out about your bisexual
how [__] up is that hey hey keep your
head up definitely God Bless yeah I
support him of course [__] up like
he's got a rough year kiss my ass with
these people who do that this I can't
stand social media I can't stand these
dregs this is just such like but that
but that's you know you cowered behind
your keyboard you [__] but B what do we
always say sit and watch the bodies flow
down the road listen again your brain
won't you say anything else that doesn't
work
out it doesn't work that kind of person
you enjoy that but here's I I don't know
anything I've only been alive for 56
years but I I what do I know but um
that person I post that video of that
him doing that stuff I don't get the BET
what's the benefit because they are they
are people who hate their own lives uh
the one thing I know also is that when
you see people do stuff like that they
hate themselves so much that they don't
think that they're worth anything so
they just rail against existence in
general so but I I just don't get why
you would release that like what better
because you can because social media
allows you to put down but also you
can't take credit for it it's a felony
it's called revenge porn it's a felony
so it's like so you post it anonymously
yeah just to ruin their people like that
there are people who enjoy hurting
people for no reason
it's an old boyfriend maybe I'm just not
wired that way I just I don't understand
it because like why would you do that
that's right because you're healthy that
way because I'm too busy to be coming
after people I don't know what the [__]
I've been busy even if I worked that
would name a job even if I worked
part-time at [__] Radio Shack yeah
well there are people out there try to
be out of business some people some
people suck yeah you ain't lying and
we've learned the hardware a lot of
great people we've learned the hard way
haven't we be it's okay
it's okay keep by the way that don't let
that change you don't let that change
your generosity just be a little bit
more careful but don't let it change
your generosity yeah let's go tighten
the ship up a little bit it's okay
well tighten up I mean like you're
looking at the crew here
like we've got all the fat cut all the
crazy got the crew
hey
that's for sure what else you got Jen
all right real quick just to show you
this was uh this is what I was working
on yesterday you know these videos make
me cry dude no there's not a video and I
didn't post this I was gonna post this
but I was like since the first time we
met and we built the first Studio
together look at how skinny Brandon was
what a [__]
that's us actually putting the studio
together together that's great
so I did all this stuff
that was our picture in Australia I
think yeah Australia
you and Jay and that great picture I
forgot where this is from but great
shots buddy yeah and then I was gonna
end it with the video of the the tiger
remember you're like doing the skit yeah
[__] dude
we've been through some [__] yeah dude
yeah let's make the real I'm like oh
you're gonna talk [__] I'm like [__]
God I would have cried you should um
why don't you and Chin get it over
I'm just telling you what if I send a
video of me and Chin hooking up and sent
to Jeff Molina go hey dude what's up eat
off you post this oh my gosh but good
for Jeff Molina man
it's just put yourself whoever it is if
you're hating on me put yourself in my
shoes or Jeff Molina any of these people
online you want to hate on just be human
for one second and imagine what [__]
they have to deal with that won't happen
it's crazy I don't understand it I do
not understand it I can't I wish I could
yep can't all you can do is be you B
yeah that's all you need
well you can also
kill everyone
that's the other problem you can also
get it yeah I would help me out if I
couldn't you can get one of those
armored cars with just a huge like
well anyway you get a helicopter gunship
you find out where they live hey these
two guys Sam posted this oh yeah this is
Sam tripley is so funny no this is my
this is the greatest shout out to Jared
Olson one he goes it's almost like a
sketch of a fake sketch it does it looks
like like a Saturday life open of them
mimicking the Jesse Smollett
they're just reenacting what happened so
far with the Justice Melody the two
Nigerian Brothers by the way we can't
play a lot as I'm sure because it was
from Fox or NBC but uh Fox yeah go to
slam trip Tucker go to Sam Trip Lee
you'll see it uh and plus listen to
their voices I thought they would have a
Nigerian
because originally they did right
they're probably like second generation
Nigerian the best part of the video is
when they're like they're pretending
they're reenacting they're like hey
isn't that the gay from Empire yeah yeah
they said it way worse and they're like
this is America yeah they call them the
f word hilarious they took our beautiful
bench this is where we waited for Jesse
to come before we attack them these guys
don't care here's my thing well how how
did why did Jesse hire them chin do we
know because he was they were their
trainers no I think he met them on set
didn't you they were yeah were they as
trainers he paid them as trainers but
then I think there was some like you
know thing where he wanted to own them
too yeah yeah
there was a rumor that he was he hooked
up with the one yeah we're paying them
to hook up or something I don't know
I've seen way too much First 48 I would
guess the guy in the turtleneck
right well I don't know where turtleneck
like that yeah but they denied it so
they may not have been anything of
course they did yeah
but they're bodybuilders but I mean if
they're gonna pay to do this like fake
crime or they're gonna get paid to do
this fake crime who knows what else they
would get paid for well Jess Jesse Smith
find out how much he paid them so
there's 3 500 bucks oh so they were like
all right I'll do it what do you want me
to do the funniest part is called The
Noose the Rope off Jesse's face and took
and put over his head the best is Jesse
uh hired them uh wait no what was it he
he
I can't remember you want more money I
thought this would bring no he wrote
them checks
he wrote them checks did you ever see
for did you ever see uh what was his
name um the two basketball players were
like whatever you do don't write checks
but I think in Jesse's mind he's like
I'm gonna write for Jim or for like oh
so that's like proof which is just come
on so I'll play this little last clip
watch the full thing on Sam tripoli's
Instagram it's just Sam Tripoli but I'll
play this this is another clip of it I
thought he was a good actor but I also
was thinking that this guy is a fraud
just lying to these people lying through
his teeth and not caring yeah I think he
shot a teared and I want a little gay
boy who might watch this to see he's an
actor back this is crazy man
it's so true though right you can all
see through this dude crazy man like he
was acting like and crying and saying
all stuff like come on yeah he said
Justin Smollett is a sociopath terrible
a narcissist his sister's hot as hell
yeah she is yeah
just a bad guy you do
we're on the hot food oh God bless her
there's another current event I got from
uh another current event I saw from Sam
tripoli's uh Instagram
18 I've been hooking up with him
or resigned because of uh having sex
with the prisoners and then let me show
you some of these girls though this is
the work it's interesting so that's a
jail looks really nice right yeah yeah
I was a workout gym all that stuff
leaving yourself I guess this is one of
the girls but I'll show you the ones
that I thought not mad this one what
was a prison girl that's like Lady Gaga
on the left yeah Gaga and she hooked up
with someone his name is Rosa [__]
guys I mean you know and they're
probably dangerous give it a break give
it a rest guys
uh that's a different girl he's really
pretty she's like a like kind of a
brother smart you get young hot girls in
there wait wait go back go back go back
go back huh she's gorgeous that's the
one that was in this yeah hot girls with
these muscular rocked out criminals come
on so that was her and by the way what
is the uh what's the crime you're not
supposed to hook up with prisoners
you're a prison guard you can't be a
prison guard shock and Winger on the
side Brian that's a love affair look at
that
oh she was jailed for one year uh after
having an affair with dangerous criminal
you know we can't have that but I mean
put her in jail for a year for having
sex with a guy
it is weird right it is a little fun
give her a fine her 20 bucks
yeah she's cool yeah I'll post and
there's some other ones so hold on this
girl hooked up with this guy so that's
where it is this is the one that writes
oh that's a kid they're both young and
they're they're they're probably looking
on the rights y'all you're spending all
your time with them I don't know I mean
I think it's great there's another one
I've been on the rights just like
anything putting them in jail they're
putting him in jail for a year are you
kidding me they toss them away for a
year you're gonna bring those baby green
eyes around me and I expect me to try I
mean yeah Shooters shoot that one girl
was just like dime
they're all awesome also the people that
hire them hey bro hire warlocks only and
even then they want to get fired yeah I
I mean the inmates are after dude after
two weeks of training camp you're like
hey man that warlock you've got 18
female jail I mean come on yeah why not
what are we doing here I know
um all right so this one I can't I'll
play a tiny bit of the audio but this is
another Vin Diesel post and then so this
is what he wrote
as opposed
our ancestors we must never forget them
or their wisdom which resides in our
souls stay inspired stay human before
you play chin if Brian hits it big this
is gonna be your experience you're gonna
be the exact same there is no doubt
about this in the same amount of here
hit it so all it is by the way because
it's so long it's just a horse running
around and there's like beautiful music
well you know what dude
[Music]
we used to see a big shotgun from Vin
Diesel cool
and so he just posted and this goes on
for like a lot stay inspired and stay
here never forget them or their wisdom
which resides in our souls stay inspired
okay all right well listen he's such an
interesting he's just so rich he's so
rich it's so rich oh that's and Georgie
found this one oh thanks for bringing
nothing oh
[Laughter]
that's of course there's a goatee that's
a squeezy nose man okay well Jay yeah
this looks like J sharp it does wait a
minute charges dropped against driver
open fire on I-95 in Miami
this guy is blasting out his window yep
so apparently this guy his name is
popper he actually cut off someone else
and then it became a road rage incident
the guy threw a water bottle at him and
he thought it was a gunshot so he took
out his gun and started firing at him oh
I think everyone's fine but obviously
that seems like something that would be
highly illegal but since there's the
stand your ground law there
yeah it's good for him yeah wow jeez and
he shot he's shot with this guy I
remember this have you guys ever been in
road races Mr Popper yes exactly that's
what makes him even funnier
no I've never wanted to throw something
oh I have but then I'm like nothing
looking at this I'm like there's no way
in hell I'm gonna throw a water bottle
wait Mr Popper was shot at actually what
no yeah
he thought he was yeah do you know he
thought with the water bottle I thought
he was shot he fired the gun where no he
faces charge of including aggravated
assault with a firearm after the road
raid incident however the Miami-Dade
State Attorney's Office recently dropped
the charges against popper because he
fights again right right poppers
attorney Robert has said that the charge
was dropped because Florida stand your
ground law I think I understand your
ground law Mr Popper's perfectly
reasonable and justified in his actions
Mr Popper was shot at but I think it was
just him thinking he was shot I think he
was shot at
it was a water bottle
okay if someone actually shot at someone
and the other person shot at their back
then I'm telling you
I need a shot at otherwise he wouldn't
have hold on and the driver who pulled
that hang on a shot at another driver's
car hold on let me see which one oh yeah
the other drivers the other driver
tailgate them proper proper brake check
them the other driver pulled alongside
popper through a water bottle popper
claim it was gunfire and returned firing
con okay see this so he thought he
thought it was gunfire I'm very
surprised because the water box right
but if it's loud and you run over on
your car and goes pop you're like Jesus
Christ and you're in that extreme you
know what happened to my girl she was
like after my gig she was on the street
in Venice and this car drove by we had
the video couldn't make out who it was
and this dude took a Fiji bottle a whole
Fiji bottle as they were driving and
threw it as hard as it could right at
her man hit her right in the chest what
oh dude she couldn't that person was
black and blue she couldn't move her
arms person was me yeah she couldn't
move her arm I couldn't get into the
sold out show dude yes son of a [__]
they threw a Fiji water bottle yeah but
like and would you really mess her up
nothing yeah I was I just got well I
went and got the video I called oof
it was like a full feed you want about
the square one yes and it was uh it was
it was it was a full like they didn't
yeah they're heavy they didn't take it
out
they're expensive too yeah right so
someone probably rich harder
Chief she's not fall down and he put her
in an arm bar and she almost died
uh so so Eddie Izzard is not transgender
no number one Eddie Izzard is a
transvestite I think that's the words oh
gosh I wasn't gonna say that but he oh
my God Eddie didn't get the sex uh
surgery as far as I know I I tried
Googling it to see to see if he had the
body or she had the surgery bottom chin
he did what no they call it bottom
surgery yeah so I heard that did it they
didn't get it I heard that didn't
but uh anyways this is she or he changed
his name
yeah I'm um to Susie I'm not with all of
it but okay
this whole pronoun thing is if that was
under your bed you would be scared [__]
well my problem with all of this is is
it with this pronoun stuff is that you
can say you're a woman because you feel
like it so let me just follow this
there's no science no but hold on so you
I I feel like a woman therefore I'm a
woman and everyone must refer to me as a
woman not only must you refer to me as a
woman you're allowed to before even
getting any operation or even estrogen
go into a dressing room or a bathroom
where my daughter at 14 is and change in
front of her and take a shower or all
that stuff I am against that I think I
don't think a woman is healing I don't
think a man has a feeling I think
there's biology and and I I also have a
major problem with the fact that they
are giving children puberty blockers and
double mastectomies and that is I'm glad
you cleared this out because I thought
you were on the other but this is this
is the case in California and I think
it's criminal I think it's worse than
bad I think it's criminal and I stand
against it so [__] off yeah I don't know
I'm not I'm not I'm not gonna do [__] uh
well I'll speak my mind I don't know
what I can do I can fight for
legislation that makes that illegal if
you want to be 18 and do whatever you
want God bless you if that's what you
want to do if you want to you want to
get my kids start if you want to start
teaching my children that gender is a
construct
so I don't know how deep Eddie is or
gets into the hole like you know that's
fine
this musician right you know his actor
and a comedian yeah so he's been a
writing great great stand-ups he's
amazing Eddie Izard is amazing in every
way Eddie has been doing it for a long
time and he has just been dressing like
a woman for long he just likes to do it
why is that I think he was amazing
apparently a lot of people get off on
that stuff okay I don't know what the
deal is I don't care if ediuser wants me
to call him a woman I will if Eddie
Izard wants to call change his name
Elena and he wants me okay I will yeah
do your thing no problem it's kind of
chill about it he's like yeah that's
what I was just I don't yeah do whatever
you want I'm a huge fan
stop trying to tell my kids that it's a
concert yeah I don't think Eddie's doing
that though yeah that's a difference
well no people in California are but
Eddie's not part of that and you're
allowed to you're allowed to go into a
woman well you got people in man in
women's jail but that's not Eddie's
thing yeah I don't know her words call
me this I understand you got a dude I
don't know where it stands with
bathrooms whoa now the butt reduction
stops so Blac Chyna who Brennan met at
the radio when you went to breakfast
club right yeah saw her passing by she
just she just lives two miles from me
there you go uh apparently she wants to
get rid of all of her feelings dissolve
her feelings and her butt implants she
was funny about it though that's what I
love she goes I started to look like the
Saul yes and she said that she
referenced that yeah
so she's getting rid of all that she's
yeah she wants to like uh I bet she is
so she got rid of her face now she does
look better the ass her ass was getting
out of control
she's pretty girl see her there
too much baby a lot of fillers um
uh yeah I still see a lot of work but
it's fine well no she's getting she's
getting rid of him now like she's in the
hospital
because I'm sure cutting and whatever
the [__] did you're gonna see a lot of
this I think right there's Fashions
changed people want to be she looks good
though that Kim Kardashian ass is out of
control I was like
that that that that Brazilian booty yeah
and so if there's I can understand
putting a little fat in there but BBL is
what the kids call it yeah some of it
gets out of control she did Family Feud
Kim Kardashian I was like it was a hot
second ago Dude hold on I was like crazy
no yeah I mean I'd never seen I didn't
know how crazy that that surgery is
surgery to do it but she went crazy but
Blac Chyna's message as well on top of
wanting to get rid of the fillers and
she's saying she did silicone implants
which is not Brazilian but Brazilian
uses your own fat and silicone could be
very dangerous it could be deadly so
that's why she's like yeah that's smart
if you uh well listen oh excuse me but
there they just grew antlers on a mouse
I'm gonna say it again I'm gonna say it
again
they just grew antlers
on a mouse
do you know that
okay
so bring it up chin
bring it up why do we care I'll tell you
why we care because we can put antlers
on anything though if you can grow
antlers on a mouse
that's not real is it those are
photoshopped but that's cute as [__]
okay I think that's real
no this might be real oh that was just
okay
um
that looks terrible that ruined my day
but let's see what they're saying though
now hold on Brian why do we give a [__]
my mini Amazon my sponsoring dear jeans
well we give a [__] because if you can
grow if you can grow antlers on a mouse
we're not mice why can't I grow hair on
my head
I I feel like antlers are a lot harder
to grow than some hair it's a fair point
why you guys spending someone Anders
antlers mice don't need antlers I need
hair I'll tell you what you know when I
gave up all hope for your hair is when I
realized Donald Trump and LeBron James
who have all the money in the world yeah
I can't do it Elon Musk nothing nothing
I can go get an old school hair
transplant I'm waiting on
get away grow antlers on a mouse
I was wondering where you're gonna go
with this that's where I'm going and
that's fair that's a cute mouse though
if he does get antlers it's amazing
it's really weird
that looks cute it's been a hard day for
mice eat getting eaten by arowanas how
do you mean by the air one of those Is
that real no no that's completely
definitely Photoshop yeah I thought it
was real uh wait what okay we'll do this
one real quick and then end with that so
this one is a little bit older this is
the Grammy Awards and Busta Rhymes meets
Trevor Noah so I'll just play for you
real quick
what it is right now
Trevor's singing one of the buses songs
[Music]
that's a fan that's cool because like
Trevor's like you know I love the bus is
like old school yeah
you're smart
that's pretty hard that is pretty old
but uh so this one is another from
Georgia it's funny this guy's getting
all serious with this girl you know have
you seen this video
[Music]
[Laughter]
is like not up in here
[Music]
[Laughter]
I don't know what this problem
she's all I feel like I really have
feelings
that's what you get for having a little
[__] on your part
all right well uh do you know your name
yeah I'm flying in like that road to
Tacoma Thursday and Friday Saturday
Tacoma Comedy Club Tacoma is this
Thursday Friday Saturday March 23rd
through the 25th Pasadena one show only
April 1st shopping friends B if you're
in town come on down Atlanta Georgia
April 13th through the 15th Spokane
April 27 28th La Jolla Comedy Store just
announced June 2nd through the 4th then
your boys jumped across the pond
um Leon Edwards is open up for me uh
Belfast June 15th Glasgow wow Glasgow
Belfast Glasgow Manchester
London Cardiff Dublin Dublin Dublin say
all that all right Dublin yeah but
Tacoma this weekend and Brian your dates
I don't care
I'm not mentioning them just for spite
they did tell me how it's worth Slack
could have been great because you didn't
bring it up now at West Nyack is a mall
and it's a it's the club is all the way
out there be no it's it's 40 minutes
outside of New York City
so that's what West Nyack was uh I love
the staff I love the staff I love John
the manager and uh and I had a great
show great shows but um it's uh bar huh
it's just out it's that it's in a
strange piece here in New York a few
times yeah sounding always great all
right well love you kids Tacoma see you
this weekend bye bye